Speaker 1: Let's go next to I'd like to speak to
Lyn in California. Lynn, how are you today? Fine.
How are you? I'm doing well. What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: First, I want to thank you for being a
calm and informative source of progressive news.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you.
Speaker 4: And I've been
watching the Rittenhouse trial.
And you've made it clear what your
opinion is. I'm wondering if there's
any testimony that would change that.
Speaker 1: You mean, is there is there is
there testimony that would make me think
that a guilty for homicide is coming?
Yes. You know, what's really, really tough about
an affirmative defense like self-defense is that
you're not denying that he did the thing you're
basically saying. His state of mind was that he
thought he might be killed. And with a standard
of beyond a reasonable doubt, it's reckless unless
the circumstances were different. I find it very
hard for the prosecution to prove a negative that
at no time did Kyle fear for his life. So I don't
really think it's about testimony. I think it's
about the circumstances and the facts.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I agree, as much as I
would like to see him found guilty. I
can definitely see how a juror would
see if there was reasonable doubt as well.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and the thing about I would
like to see him be guilty. I think that he's
guilty of a lot of things that aren't crimes
like, for example, it's an example of disastrous
parenting where a 17 year old even thinks that
this is something that you would do. I think
it's an example of our disastrous and toxic
gun culture in the United States militia ideology
of vigilantism. It's all of these different things
for what he's charged with, and we we have
to see what the jury instructions are.
It doesn't seem that guilty would
be in line with the case that the
reason that the defense will reasonably
make about self-defense. That's my take.
Speaker 4: Agree, and the only thing he
said he knows about air 15s are they make
him look cool. He doesn't know the damage
they do or the ammunition that's used,
Speaker 1: which he may have been lying about.
Quite frankly, I think that was part of making,
you know, stepping away from being very
aware of exactly what the gun would do.
I think that was he. I think he feigned
ignorance on that. But still, you know,
it's all, it's crazy. It's all crazy.
Speaker 4: OK, thank you, and I agree
with your girlfriend, the mustache should
Speaker 1: really go, Oh, wow, OK, well,
it may go soon. It may go soon. OK,
thank you. All right, there's Lynn
from California. Very much appreciate that
call. Let's go. Oh, I don't know. I mean,
there's just so many people here. Oh, let's go
to Ohio. What about Maria in Columbus, Ohio?
Maria, you're on the air, simply
on mute and will be able to chat.
And, Maria, from Ohio, last chance to
unmute yourself so that we can talk.
Well, that's too bad. I was looking
forward to speaking with Maria.
Let's try instead. Why don't we go to Steve
from Illinois, Steve, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, how are you? Good. I was wondering
what you thought, I mean, I know that you probably
agree with the mandate. I was wondering what
you thought of the Biden administration still
telling companies to follow their vaccine mandate,
even though it's getting held up in the courts
right now? Don't you kind of find that wrong in
the sense is that the courts can't hold it up
in the Biden administration telling companies
to not follow what the courts are saying?
Speaker 1: Well, correct me if I'm wrong, the
that requirement call it a protocol or mandate
whatever you want to call it. I don't believe
it goes into effect for several more weeks,
right? So I think my understanding you correct
me if I'm wrong, my understanding is that the
Biden administration is saying plan on this
being something you that will be in place.
I understand that right now is being frozen, but
it hasn't actually gone into effect yet, has it?
Speaker 2: No, the Mary is going to affect bye,
guys, like the fact that like it's getting held up
right now and then our guys, them saying continue
going on so that planning on it to come to the
fact that I guess, do you think that the body may
show these things and get through the courts then?
Or do I think it might be that it seems like, no,
Speaker 1: I think it will be through the courts.
I think it's I mean, Ronald Klain's said on
on NBC, I think it was over the weekend. We
believe ultimately this is going to be upheld. You
know, the New Orleans Circuit Appeals Court there
is very conservative. This is unlikely to be a
decision that stays. So I think I mean, listen,
we'll know soon. I don't think the Biden
administration is doing anything wrong by saying,
we believe this ultimately will be in force. Yeah.
Speaker 2: All right. I see, I guess I see your
point. When I was looking at it,
I guess in my mind, it came off
more. Keep doing. Even though it's getting
held up rather than it looks like it's going
to be go through on that end. Well, certainly
Speaker 1: we keep vaccinating is something like,
listen, continue vaccinating
employees makes perfect sense.
Speaker 2: I, yeah, I get the vaccination taxation
point on there, I guess I was, I guess I my
you explained it very well, like the situation
is going on. I guess when I was looking into it
kind of came off in a different way on that tone.
Speaker 1: Fair enough. All right. I appreciate
the call for you. Thank you there,
Steve from Illinois. Very powerful call.